greetings planet Houston and may I on
this very special day wish you all a
merry zodmas
as many of you know I do not celebrate
Christmas I celebrate softness but some
of you might be wondering how do I
celebrate softness I'm glad you asked
Houstonian slave it's very simple first
of all there is no Jesus or God so these
are and we do not huddle around the dead
tree we huddle around a rock and you
carve the rock into a makeshift statue
of meaning if for some reason I am out
there but rest assured I will try to be
there to punish you for not seeing me on
softness actually black is one of 50
traditional South miss colors which
include chick Lac obsidian black
charcoal black midnight black licorice
Black Jack black shaft black
weapons-grade black gray steel grey
cloudy gray ocean grey steel gray I am
Greg Greg Greg and puce instead of
Christmas lights we will stuff people
with pure uranium and then hang them
from our ceiling instead of mistletoes I
will finally get my toes the fire
missiles and instead of kissing people
under them you will die candy canes will
be replaced by cinnamon handcuffs they
shall be used to corral people into the
worship centers wait till I tell you
about the worship centers inside there
will be shows and entertainment all
dedicated to me I will have the
Rockettes they will all be dressed as
salt all Christmas movies will be
replaced by the film babies day out
because I really like that will be
populated Stuckey's will be stuffed with
more stockings sites will be stuffed
with socks and the rest of your clothes
will be hung by the chimney with care to
Camila ate you if you are petulant you
will be sent outside naked in the cold
those Altimas cookies will have no
raisins in them and instead of milk I
require a cup of liquid nitrogen I will
come down the chimney to every house and
scream at you those who do not follow my
orders will be beaten those who do
follow my orders will be beaten it
slightly less severely Christmas carols
will all be replaced by songs or the
occasional dirty Limerick about the son
of jor-el
the Salvation Army will be replaced by
the damnation army all proceeds will go
to the Children's Fund to give me more
money and all of this will last
throughout the entire ultimate season
which lasts 364 days of the year when
they offer my birthday that's right
Zod misses upon you there is no escaping
it that's the only word I can use what
other word would I use of course I
haven't thought about what else could it
mean I mean what else could it mean okay
um let's get one thing perfectly clear
why not I mean I'm just not not that
there's anything wrong with that but I
assure you I'm not straight arrow
I mean okay the clothing can kind of be
deceiving but it's it's really not what
you think
listen when I say Neal I mean it as in a
submissive pose okay that's not helping
now that I care because I don't nothing
wrong with that so cool I mean ask
yourself when that kind of man have this
kind of has that okay well ask yourself
another question um would that kind of
man
travel around with the person who looks
like that okay also a bad example
um here's a woman I travel with she
doesn't look at all like a lesbian does
she actually she does a lot okay look I
spend most of my time chasing a big
strong man who wears blue and red spend
a contrasting pebble deeper you know
what fine go ahead and think it doesn't
matter to me
I'm so not bad that it doesn't matter
I'm not but it doesn't matter it's like
calling me a banana I'm not a banana
that's weird of you to think that but I
don't care so you think I'm a banana who
being forced to tell you that Neil is
not a guy's name either you know what
you can have the stupid planet this is
General Zod saying merry zodmas happy
new standards solar year and are not I'm
not